jesus lizardo starting for the athletics
and dallas said it best it's been a long
time since he's been on the mound
so good change up there and he gets
machado so so far so good for lazada and
zach davies on the hill tonight for the
friars
getting ready for start number eight of
the padres uniform
it's sharply and diving at second base
quarter worth they get the out nicely
done great stretch there by tatis as
well turn himself into a first baseman
right there
and with that long reach able to reach
out there and get that for out number
one the major league debut for campusano
about to take place here in oakland he
is the dh in tonight's game we're
talking about a guy it's not about a guy
who's got experience at double a or aaa
level he's straight out of abel and
there it is
sit down
welcome to the big leagues
[Music]
that is that is a baptism
by very definition there's robbie
grossman he's trying to get their first
base runner to second base
there's a shot right field fair ball
matt olson digging for third
and they're gonna hold him up late and
olson runs through the stop sign the
throw to the plate is not in time he's
in there see here if there's enough
there to overturn it the padres are
challenging the safe call
on the field okay foot is down uh there
now it comes up now where's the tag does
he get him on the left knee before his
foot comes down the second time oh here
comes the jury right now
he is out
out at the plate it is overturned wow
two down here in the fifth and here's
trent grisham trent grisham got the
single
in the third
this one is lying to left field and a
base hit to left center field meyer is
coming around to score heading to third
as camp busano throw to second is late
and the padres strike first on top one
to nothing trent christian with a two
out rbi double and the padres are on the
board one to nothing
here's fernando big a b for him right
here camposano goes to third four fires
at second high fly ball well hit from
fernando off the wall by the 400 sign in
dead central coming around to score big
time head double by fernando two more
come home my padres three the oakland a
is nothing
just unloaded
the deep deep dead center
and fernando probably wondering how this
thing didn't get out of here because he
hit that about as well as any ball he's
hit this year but night time at the
coliseum it does not fly
day time oh boy it flies and we'll have
two day games tomorrow and sunday but at
night you've got to really really hammer
it to get it out of here
first and third now two down and eric
hosmer
trying to keep it going back up the
middle into center field to base it for
hosmer tatis will score and the padres
up their lead to four to nothing eric
hosmer driving in a run well the padres
had gone 14 innings without a run and
they come up with four quick ones
jam shot chapman dives gets up his throw
to first and they got him
so matt chapman with a sensational play
and it saved a run
against the athletics
and the boys top of the order trying to
add on to this lead
[Applause]
fly ball sent out towards deep right
center field back goes piscotty at the
wall that ball should be gone it's above
the wall
and tatis will touch them all
fernando tatis junior connects on his
14th home run of the year
he'll take his time getting around as
the padres have added to their lead on
top five to nothing fernando tatis jr
i know we've said this many many times
and
we'll go on saying it but
this kid is unbelievable we just saw him
rifle a ball at 16 degrees off his bat
off the center field wall the trajectory
of this one i thought it was going to
stay in the arc
but this ball you can see it change
direction off the concrete out there
nobody out top of the seventh padres
lead the a's five to nothing
this one is in the air to deep left
shutter field back goes l'oreal look it
up it's gone manny machado taking it out
of the yard the padres go back to back
tatis jr and now machado and the padres
take a six nothing lead in oakland
fifth time this year that the padres
have gone back to back three times it's
been fernando and manny
here's luis camposano d.h today 0 for 2
making his major league debut and the
first pitch to him is hit well down the
right field line in the air towards the
corner and that one's going to go a home
run for luis camposano his first major
league hit goes over the fence and
opposite field homer and the padres make
it seven to nothing here in the eighth
welcome to the big leagues
welcome to the big leagues luis caposano
[Applause]
gotta love the reception in the dugout
good for the kid
welcome to the big leagues
fly ball headed to center field trent
grisham is back there
and grisham will make the catches the
padres win